one i think one in three or one in six
players on the field
had family members that played in that
yeah see my dad was a drug dealer i can
beat that
that's easy or you could be a really
good drug dealer i could that is true
you got to watch the wire
yeah you're right did you guys watch the
wire i love the white yeah
three seasons what what you like how
many is it six six
wait six of them you didn't even i fell
off after like four you didn't even get
to meet marlo
nope i fell off after four bro that's
the greatest i watched it
annually like every year right you think
it's a great show but you
you like power what's other show you
guys watch we watched
sopranos is a great show by the way
number overrated overrated for real
oh i just started it i fell asleep in
the middle of it of course she did
because it's from the 90s and there's
not much going on there oh really
everyone jerks it off because it's the
first of its kind for like
i love lobster stuff i like that like
i'm obsessed with it so you wouldn't
watch
all i read is like i want godfather's
legitimacy
the best television i've ever seen is
yellowstone
all right all right this guy is on this
yellow it makes me want to move to
montana or you know
okay you got to finish the wire though
and you should you should too your dad's
a drug though
i know why is that he's not a drug
dealer anymore anymore i'm trying to put
him i'm sorry i apologize
he's not what show did you get into that
when it ended you were sad
i know [ __ ] were crying over game of
thrones when it ended
i love game of thrones as well loved
obsessed with it come on man it's well
documented on here i
wore [ __ ] white walker shirts and
[ __ ] but i was
you like the white walkers yeah bro what
i rooted for the white wine
i was a snow guy i was with snow you
were you know how tiny snow is he's
fight for but dude
but did you see that sword come on he
don't want to kill you sward
sword sword
you know what i i want i thought i had
like a wolf a wolf like they had i
didn't know what
i didn't know what a husky was right so
i was dating this girl
i was like yo you got like a shed like a
[ __ ] yo i was like girl where
you get this game of thrones wolf at she
was like there's a hug
like [ __ ] it's a husky i didn't know
i was like are you going to thrones is
dope though game of thrones is dope
every set win that was your show yeah
game of thrones is my show
i don't think i've been attached to
another show like that since i just kind
of watch them i can't vikings was good
though
oh yeah you love like chin love like you
and your girl netflix and chill
no the only shows i remember that got
sad when it ended was dawson's creek
and the office yeah
i got lost after a while but i remember
when it was off at its best it was it
was amazing then it kind of went crazy
with will ferrell and
it was great though office was great
damn that's
it i respect that thank you thank you
though right i respect that yeah yeah
yeah
wow hard feelings take heartache for me
with seventh heaven
heaven
miners the whole time i don't know if he
was doing i don't know
but like i know he had gotten in trouble
yeah what else slap true blood did you
get in trouble
oh yeah new orleans vampires like hell
yeah it was good until the end the fair
you're off cat you're the fairy stuff
was good
[ __ ] take the fairy stuff out dude
people hate on seasons five and six i
thought it was so
good see everything up until the fairy
part i was into
you was into it yeah i loved it and then
they were like oh she's a fairy
yeah i think you're on a different show
i think we're on different shows they're
on this like yeah you know like
i'm with you i watched a lot chin i will
chin i'm still trying to find out who a
is chin i will guarantee you like yellow
stuff i
at this point i have to watch it now i
know i'm watching it i'm boring
yeah let me tell you something britney i
swear to god if i get cause i'm gonna
sit my girl down my queen i don't know
what else you like though
like what would you and your girl watch
what we watch oh housewives
real housewives watch that everything i
watch it yeah i used to work for bravo
dude
which one is your favorite oh real
housewives orange county gotta
wait see that's why everyone like
atlanta i don't know i haven't watched
atlanta and that's
atlanta's good kind of rudolph
millennials
atlanta is good you're like did you
don't catch that because i got it
most people like atlanta or new jersey i
love jersey i love new york and i'm with
beverly
hills and i'm with potomac now see i
never got into potomac
but then again me too because we had to
cover it but yeah [ __ ] you better get
into it i like going to gizelle and
getting
well nick and uh i can't get in those
shows man man it's great bro but i like
but i like i like power i watch anything
i like uh see i
i think hbo i've watched teen mom since
2009.
talk about it who was your favorite one
teen mom uh i was a bit
fair with i was fun oh the girl porno
yeah i watched it
yeah i like watched it it was cool the
poor and i watched that
yeah yeah that's why i thought i've been
invested since two hours
she was a pregnant come on and she had
like implants i had to see what it was
about
she was at the comedy store all the time
she was i'm trying to do comedy
i don't know hopefully not oh i'm saying
a single mother you guys i thought i
thought she was
maybe yeah you probably right hopefully
not don't do that
i feel bad for the child now but yeah
team i got really into teen mom then t
mom
that this new season that teen mom which
i'm always into invested 209 dude
so i gotta figure it out but then after
that they have this i love
that right they have this this addiction
show of kid they go to this school in
boston
and it's kids who are addicts and
instead of getting
you know when kids like let's say you're
in high school you get caught with
cocaine or something you get to spend
for the year and this teacher
god bless her she makes no money she
takes all these
[ __ ] reject kids who have addiction
and she's like
well here's the problem is if they're
going to regular public school they get
caught with drugs they suspend them he
goes
so these kids get suspended of course
they can do drugs yeah she's like they
never get better so then they just miss
out on the school year
so she takes those kids in and they drug
test them and even if they relapse
they're all right they have a safe place
but they're still learning yeah but bro
you got to watch that's so dumb
stuff like that that's the i'm going to
send to you yes it's only four or five
episodes
wait why is so short not a lot of times
it's like an hour long
there's a lot of kids but dude the
fourth episode spoiler in three two one
they're showing this kid he's like the
life of the party blah blah and he's
going through a tough time
and then she's trying to talk him out of
it she goes i know when you leave here i
know you're having a tough time shoes
but when you start drinking what's gonna
happen goes
then i'll start doing weed she goes okay
then what happens there he goes then
i'll probably do cocaine she goes okay
what happens
then i do opiates she goes okay what
happens after that he goes then i'll
start
doing meth and i'll start doing this she
goes yeah we don't want to go down that
road he's
like you're right they hug she's like be
good tonight
no for real next morning
homeboy doesn't show up homeboy didn't
show up all the kids are like where's i
forget his name where's jerry bubba
where's jerry
don't show up another day goes by next
morning
died overdosed no and it could have
shaved
he could have shaved jerry well here's
here's what's [ __ ] up
is they tried getting them in uh because
he was high and he's like not doing well
so they tried getting them into help and
so he went to the hospital
and they didn't have enough beds to you
know put him in the hospital
so they're like sorry we can't take you
right now so you overdose right after
that
if there's not enough hospital beds in
the hospital they won't accept you
how does that work man we can't double
up
it was [ __ ] up we can't double up i
stepped on the air
[ __ ] up i'm telling you you got to
watch it though you're like it's so good
i do i do like watching things yeah i
like
i like you know watching stuff like that
man you know
just god bless this teacher though yeah
she's not making any money it's so
heartbreaking
and then all the teachers are funny
addicts too oh really
damn cause you know they know what
you're going through yeah they try to do
better
damn i know it's tough bro don't
i can't watch stuff like that because
i'll just start crying i don't want to
show too many
i lost a lot of people that stuff man to
drugs yeah i'm really friends
yeah my my brother i know yeah yeah when
i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
[Laughter]
grab that mic son